[Music]
Uh so I'm Philip I'm the CTO of Forish.
I'm just a psychic on this. This is
Martin Ba the to the environment
supervisor. He's going to give you so
much detail about the his process. Uh I
want to thank uh Fundre for the
invitation and giving me the occasion to
go into really more detail about uh vent
ventilation fan and um just uh we are
coming from a tiny studio based in
France. Uh we are also in in uh in Spain
in Las Palmas that's called forish that
maybe a couple of you heard of and um we
are we we're coming from commercials and
uh and video clip and um something that
uh one project that changed the game.
It's uh this projects right there. It's
like a right there. So if you are Arcane
fan that maybe that show you aren and uh
if you're Arcane fan have a look at this
uh video clip that's called I gave and
it was the reason that Riot work with us
and um we got the occasion to start
working with a tiny video company video
game company at Riot Games and uh they
did a project that's called Gings
together and we got the occasion to work
on the on the wonderful project uh maybe
tiny project that you heard of that's
called Arcane and uh we're going to
a tiny uh teaser of course for
introducing the show for maybe some
people that never seen the project
before.
[Applause]
Heat.
[Music]
Heat. Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
[Applause]
Nice. Uh so hello everyone. I'm super
glad to be here. Um so I'm Marti. I'm
the 2D environment supervisor uh at
Vish. Uh I was Lin Mattp painter on
season 1, Lin Matt painter on season 2,
moved to uh 2D asset environment uh
supervisor on season 2 and now global 2D
environment supervisor. So yeah, I'm
going to talk about like matt painting
at Vortish and how we use mattpainting
and marry uh to do uh this special uh
show that is arcane. Uh so yeah, a
little disclaimer before we start. Due
to the pace and the timing and the
duration of Arcane, uh I've started Arin
arrived in 2019.
Uh so yeah, it was super long. So we had
to stick with an old version of Mari. So
yeah, all the images that you're going
to see are based on Mari 3.3, but as
Philip was saying, we we've moved to
Mari 7. So it's going to be nice. Um so
yeah to begin with I'm going to talk a
little bit about the forish style and
the forish way of uh thinking about art
and challenges from um the music video
Gavota in 2012. Um
which put us on the spotlight of
Christian Linker who is a showrunner of
Arcane. Um that really put us on the map
to our latest show that is called
Welcome to Nexus. But yeah, we we always
trying to have this kind of print
painterly look. Um, so we really want
you to feel that you're really um diving
into an art book. So it's when you look
at concept art, we are you you really
have the sensation for most of the
movies that there is kind of a a change
between the concept art and the final
result. So we at forish we always try to
really bring you into the to the concept
art. So we really want you the
characters that you see on screen you
really want them to to move. Um so we
try to bring the art and the paint
directly on the screen. Like for example
this color script we we try to stick to
it uh as a painterly feeling and ply
look up to the final result. So it's not
really a matter of like thinking about
Forish as a 3D studio. We are more like
thinking about ourself our 2D animation
studio with live action cameras and 3D
sets. So to achieve this style uh we try
to bridge the gap between a prop and uh
what is painted background. So and we
have like one constraint is what we call
the Scooby-Doo effect. So it's really
obvious what you see on screen, what is
a background, what is a props, what is a
character. So it's all those kind of
stuff that we try to um do to so the
viewers really needs to always have the
question in mind like is it a prop um is
it a matt painted matt painting is it 3D
or is it 2D um it's always what we
really want you to like have those
question in mind when you are looking
about at arcane so as a general rule Um
what we can call a prop is something
that uh the characters are endling. So
you can have like um guns, weapons, uh
clothes, uh specific objects, vehicles
and stuff like that. And environment is
kind of all the the rest. So you can
have um some uh stuff in the foreground
background. Uh really what's not moving
is really uh the M painting. So it's
always like try to be as simple as
possible. If you can do that in Matt
painting, do it in Matt painting. You
don't have to uh really overthink uh
stuff. Uh if you see like an object for
just one shot, you don't have to like
model it uh and really on all the the
360 uh uh turn is like really like if
you just see an asset, just paint it.
It's it's way more simple. Um and uh
yeah just cherish craftsmanship. So as
Gandis the our texting supervisor will
tell you better than me.
>> We paint it.
>> Yeah. It's really the essence of what we
are doing is like if we want you to feel
that it's painted, we just paint it.
There's no shortcuts uh from the sky to
the background uh to the vegetation in
the front. Yeah. Everything is painted
uh from the camera point of view. So
it's really like the matt painting
techniques pushed to the really like uh
for all the shots.
So it's exactly the same when we want
you to feel that it's made with
charcoal. We just make it with charcoal.
There is like it's kind of the easiest
and fastest way. We we are making like a
a TV series so we don't have like we
have a budget but we have some deadline
and stuff. So So yeah, we don't have
like a lot of time to do those stuff. So
we can't really like work on the shaders
that's going to feel painted and stuff.
So it's kind of easier to like Yeah. If
it's need to be made with charcoal like
do it with charcoal. We're going to scan
the shark the charcoal uh papers and
like integrate them in in comp. It's
those kind of stuff that we are always
like thinking about like if you if you
wanted to feel that it's painted, you
take a pen and you just paint it.
So yeah, it's really uh how we made
everything into the 3D scene. it just
like uh use camera mapping just
everywhere from uh the design phase to
the end of the department phases. Um so
really use it like whenever we want and
wherever we can. So on the going back to
the previous example uh everything that
you see on the shot is matt painted uh
except the the drinks on the on the
right because the characters are like
touching the glasses. So everything else
is matt painted.
Even the smoke and the corpse in this
shot are matt painted because like yeah
we it's really uh going back to keep it
simple. We don't have to like simulate a
huge simulation of smoke and stuff. You
just have to paint the smoke and just
like move them on a card. Uh it's way
easier and way faster even for the
corpse. Uh perhaps you can pose them
with the animation team and like just
repaint everything in in Matt.
But as I was saying at the beginning at
Forish we really inspired by live action
movies. So everything from photography
to cinematography is really always like
rendered into those kind of projects. So
we really try to be flexible with the
way we use camera movement and
placement. So we have a lot a lot of
camera setups. So crane tracks handle
camera we got it all. Uh so there is
like challenges for camera projection.
You can there are some point where the
camera projection approach it's not
enough. So because the camera movement
are too complex or the object movement
are really too wide. So you need to jump
to uh the kind of standard way of doing
assets is the with UVs and texturing.
So for kind of simple objects like the
chair in the background to more complex
one like the airship
to more complex environments um it's
really uh kind of use the right tool for
the job. So that's where Mari uh comes
in handy. Uh it's really kind of the the
the center of how we we can make those
kind of stuff possible. So I'm going to
dive into how we use Mary into like a
regular um process. Just so you know
like the majority of the artists that we
have on the department uh the m painting
department uh they don't they don't
really come from like a texturing
background. They are all illustrators,
concept artists. Uh they don't have a 3D
background. So, the gem to marry was
kind of an easy transition because um
it's really close to what you're used to
in in a 2D software. Uh you have the
tools, you have a layering system, uh
you have a simple UI, um you have like a
simple viewport, uh you have a super
powerful brush editor that's kind of
similar as Photoshop. So it was really
easy for us to jump between Photoshop
and Mari and uh take the same brush
packs. Uh uh you can easily like import
them into Mari. So it was really like a
smooth transition for us. Uh we've
missed like a feature in Mari 3. It was
the color jitter but it happened on the
on the the next iteration of Mari. So
I'm super glad.
So yeah, talking about the layer system,
you can easily also if you feel more
adventurous, you can jump to the nodal
approach. Uh so I'm kind of a huge fan
of that, but I know that my old team
were like you're like, "What are you
thinking, Marta?" Um so yeah, you can
really be as simple as you want and as
complex as you want with Mari. uh it was
really important for us uh to have those
uh range of um possibilities. So even if
you can just stay organized, it can be a
mess of course, but you can stay
organized. Um so talking about process,
it's kind of the same from season 1 to
season 2. um we didn't have the time to
uh change processes because it was like
a super long time and uh it was more
clean and efficient to don't change the
process at all. Um so
we tried to stay as simple and straight
to the point as possible. So
starting with some stuff that we already
know and uh work best for us was to uh
jump to the mattp painting approach at
the beginning. So using Photoshop and
Maya and taking all those informations
and bringing back to Mari. So taking
back the layer from Photoshop put them
in Mari. taking the geometries, the
cameras and from Maya and put them into
Mari. Mari allow us to project all the
stuff that we've already done in
Photoshop to uh put them and project
them onto the UVs uh through the
projectors. So you have it's a super
useful um uh tool that you import all
your cameras uh from different
softwares. So for us it was Maya and we
can really like project all the
information that we already painted
directly onto the geometry from those
projectors. Uh so you can project your M
painting from different uh point of
view. Um so but you can also like create
your own point of view um to project
what you wanted. So as you import it to
your uh camera projections, you can also
import your shot uh cameras. So you can
uh quickly and easily check all the
assets uh that you're working on
directly in the shot. So you can really
uh look for what you're missing into
resolution. if you need to um if the
camera movement is super fast, you don't
have to stay as much as um as you need
on those kind of areas, you can really
concentrate on what's going to be best
for the shots. So, it's kind of always
like a a jump between um your 3D view
and the shot uh view. So, it's really
really nice.
So you have the timeline so you can also
like check the the shot in context um
and really see all the the work that
you've done uh to see if everything is
working.
But of course most of the time uh you're
going to have like a super long list of
cameras and projectors. So it's not
really what you want. Uh sometime you
just want to be really quick and just
paint into marry. But um so you have
like an option. It's like the it's
called the quick projections. So you
don't have to feel um stuck to one
projectors. It's kind of um like a
temporary one. Uh so you can just like
take your uh camera project the stuff
that you need. And there is a useful
features like called un project is kind
of rendering the viewport to um take it
back into a 2D program. So you can
really jump between Photoshop and Mari
uh going back and forth. So you have the
option into the of those kind of options
into the projectors tab but you can also
um um go with the quick projection. I
think it's kind of for us it was kind of
the essential tool in Mari for us
because as we are not really uh we are
really simple guys so we kind of want to
do the brute force approach where if if
you move it's over when it's done it's
done so you really had to like do the
projection and project go to Photoshop
do your paint go back to Mari project
move and really do the um really the
back and forth between Mari and and
Photoshop. So, you don't have to like,
oh, I I've made a mistake. I need to go
back to the old projection.
Sorry. Um I can't come back to it. It
doesn't really matter. It's like, oh,
you can fix it um with another point of
view. It doesn't really matter. So
projectors and quick projector will get
you a long way, but ultimately you
really found yourself painting directly
into the viewport. Uh so you can um
paint to the viewport, move around, but
if you're more comfortable with like a
2D approach, you can always like jump to
the UVs and paint into the UV. So you
also have the possibility to do the
projectors and quick project from the UV
view. That's super useful. Um, and of
course, if you're uh, again not really
um, uh, familiar with painting into
Mari, you can just export your map, go
back to Photoshop, paint it to
Photoshop, reimpport the maps into Mari.
It's a bit long, but you can do that.
So
when everything was done for us uh into
the kind of albidoish uh style of
painting, we've done like some technical
passes for uh the department after us.
So uh we could do like um alternative
version of the matt painting uh perhaps
shadow pass, ID pass if the compositing
team needed some specific stuff. So like
in this example we've done like couple
of version of the of the same um uh DMP
it was like a full shadow pass a full
light pass and a mask. So most of the
time uh in the shots um we could just
use the matt painting version but like I
don't know for example the lighting team
or the compositing team wasn't really
happy with the shadows uh into a
specific shot. they can just recompose
everything with their own shadows uh
with the different passes that we gave
them. So, it was kind of a typical way
of working for us. It's always like try
to um be as simple as possible. So, if
the shadows need to be baked into the
map painting, you bake them into the map
painting. And if uh you think about um
interaction with characters and you know
that you're going to need to integrate
some shadows and stuff like that, you
need to like think about those stuff.
and um create the right passes for the
next department.
And of course uh when you finish with
all your uh texturing uh work um we have
just like a standard exporter that can
allow us to export specific UDMs and
objects. Uh so that's how we managed to
do the Jinx air chip. So yes, it's a
vehicle with high high range of motion
and uh it's handled by a lot of
characters. Uh so Jinx, Echo, I think
Warwick is like jumping on it. So there
is like a lot of interaction. Um so
you're going to ask me like yeah, but
as you were saying before like it wasn't
supposed to be like a props. Um so
yes, but no. So the first reason why we
did that into the map painting
department is because like the Jinx
airship is uh really like something
really specific that we we already saw
it into season 1 and season 2 as a
different kind of environment. It was
called the Jinx uh layer at the time but
um the so the art director we really
wanted like to to have the same approach
as a painterly style. So it's kind of
how we see it in the beginning of season
two. So we really wanted to feel uh that
it was painted the similar way because
like the the character team have their
own kind of own way of painting stuff
and we have our own kind of uh style of
painting for the environment. So it was
kind of natural for us to um do those
kind of texturing work and as it's a
massive part of some shots um it
wouldn't have been really integrated
between uh the shot the previous shot
and the next shots. So it was kind of
yeah the the the best approach for us to
really uh do that in our department uh
and of course like to avoid the as we
call the scooid effect. So, um, that's
why like we we kind of handled like the
full uh texturing of this asset. Um, so
it was really like a a really like long
process. Uh, because yeah, you see
really the this um asset from really
close-up shots to a really wide shot.
So, it was kind of always a balance
between uh what you're going to add into
uh what detail you're going to see or
not on screen. When you do a M painting,
you really focus on what you've seen on
shot in the shots. So, if it's in the
background, perhaps you're going to not
going to do a lot of detail. If it's in
close-ups, you're going to add detail.
And for those kind of asset where it's
moving from back and forth from the
camera, it's always a balance like are
we like pushing um the asset with a lot
of detail or do we do the reverse with
simple detail and we do like a um a pass
per shot. Uh it was kind of not the
approach. We approach it like yeah let's
do the the full uh detail version and
comp will adjust the level of detail
with uh stuff in nuke. So yeah it was
like 37 UDMs of 8K. Uh so it's kind of a
lot a lot a lot of of detail on the on
those kind of um assets. It's it's
really trying to push the detail from
top to bottom to close up to to the
right wide um angles. So we had the
privilege to like add all the little
detail from Jinx and what she's uh kind
of imagined like um what she's drawn
from all over the years because like
it's kind of her own little bubble. So,
she's painted everything from um like
close-ups to like some really um tiny uh
tiny detail because like on the end of
season one she's small and uh no not
like she's kind of not old but like
she's kind of young and like she's grown
up on season two. So, it's kind of like
a imagine like what she could have like
drawn all over the the the
year. So yeah, it was kind of our final
challenge because it was like a a super
long uh process to do season 1 and
season 2 and those kind of asset was
like really a good way to say goodbye to
Jinx and to let the season 2 fly out of
or end to air in Netflix. So yeah, we
still had some time to sleep some
references to the people on the team. So
you can see that we've like drawn some
cats and dogs from the team and the full
list of credits of the team. It was like
yeah um a nice way to say goodbye to the
to the show also. And um yeah like um
to to ramp up is like the mad painting
department like on season 2 we've done
like for the 7,000 shots we've done
around 4,000 m paintings. So, it's kind
of a huge amount of of paint. Yeah. It's
always like a balance between like are
we all going to do that in Matt painting
for all the shots or
are we clever and it's is it like more
efficient to do those kind of big assets
that we going to we can shoot from all
the the places. So, um on the 20 full
asset uh colored assets that we've done,
we've done nine uh 19 with Mary. So, it
was kind of a huge help and it allow us
to uh on the 7 7,000 shots um Mari allow
us to do 1,300 shots. So, it's it's kind
of a huge help uh in our process. So
yeah, if you need more information um as
uh we were saying like uh you can take
the QR code and go to the Mari website
and um yeah, if you want to have more
information about Fortish uh don't
hesitate to to to go on the website also
and um yeah and of course uh yeah thanks
[Music]
[Applause]